Now with all of this notation and
background behind us, we are ready for
the Ford-Fulkerson method.
As we'll see,
it's not really specific enough to merit
being called an algorithm, though
sometimes we will call it that anyway.
We begin by initializing the flow to 0.
Then, while there is a path from
the source to the sink in the residual
graph, we're going to calculate
the minimum capacity along this path.
We'll call that b.
And then we're going to
augment our flow,
where the augmenting flow has b along
this path and 0 everywhere else.
Once there are no more paths
in the residual graph,
we just return the current flow that
we've found in this variable f.
Let's see how this
work on a toy example.
We start with 0 flow and
the capacities shown here.
We find a path in the residual
graph that looks like this.
The minimum capacity is 1, so
we'll add that value to every edge
along the path in our original flow.
The result is a new flow,
and a new residual graph.
Here, there's only one st path.
So we'll go ahead and choose that.
Adding it to the old flow will cause
this flow across the middle to cancel
out, leaving us with this flow and
this residual network.
At this point, there are no st paths
in the residual graph, so we're done.
Great, and it's easy to confirm that
the algorithm worked in this case.
But how about in general?
First, it's easy to verify
that f is indeed a flow.
0 is a flow at the beginning,
and that each iteration
we augment the current flow,
via flow in the residual graph.
And as argued earlier,
this is indeed a flow.
Does the algorithm terminate?
Well, remember that the capacities are
all integral, so each augmenting flow,
f prime,
has to have a value of at least 1.
Otherwise the path
wouldn't be in the graph.
Therefore, we can't have more iterations
that the maximum value for a flow.
So, yes, it terminates.
How much time does it
spend per iteration?
Finding a path can be
done with search or
depth first search in time
proportional to the number of edges.
Constructing the residual graph itself
takes time proportional
to the number of edges.
And the number of edges in
the residual graph is, at most,
twice the number of edges
in the original graph.
Since we only possible
created those reverse edges.
And of course,
updating the flow requires a constant
amount of arithmetic per edge.
So all in all then, we just have
order e times each iteration.
That is, time proportional
to the number of edges.
This is a good start for
the analysis, but
it leaves us with some
unanswered questions.
Most important perhaps, is whether
the return flow is a maximum flow.
Sure, it's maximal in the sense that
we can't augment it any further.
But how do we know that with
a different set of augmenting paths or
perhaps with an entirely
different strategy altogether,
we wouldn't have ended
up with a greater flow?
Also, this bound on the number of
iterations is potentially exponential
in the size of the input, leaving
us with an exponential algorithm.
Perhaps there's some way to
improve either the analysis or
the algorithm to get
a better running time.
These two questions will occupy
the remainder of the lesson.
We'll start by showing that
Ford-Fulkerson does indeed produce
a maximum flow, and then we'll see
about improving its running time.